hello everyone we're about to get
started
my name is bear and i will be your
moderator today's webinar will be
presented by dr
valerie soda who holds a phd in
molecular and cellular biology and
genetics from dreckel university and
brad larson
a scientist whose current work has led
to publications in the journal of
biomolecular screening
and the journal of laboratory automation
among others
both valerie and brad are field
application scientists here at biotech a
apart of agilent and today they will be
discussing
3d culture methods and imaging
considerations
before we get started i want to mention
that we will be fielding questions at
the end of today's presentation
however you may submit questions at any
time using the webinar chat feature
also all registrants will receive a link
to the webinar recording via email
once it becomes available thank you all
for joining us today and with that
i will turn it over to val
so while most of this talk is dedicated
to the 3d culture methods
of mammalian cells it is important to
mention that many groups work with other
specimens that are three-dimensional in
multiple focal planes
such as algae plants protozoans
parasites or whole organisms
for which imaging considerations we will
discuss today could also apply
a majority of this webinar however
discusses the methods and considerations
for 3d culture
of cell lines
2d cell culture is a mainstay of
biological research
it is fairly simple and expensive and
reproducible
on the other end of the spectrum is in
vivo research which
may be required to solidly demonstrate
your con your research conclusions
however
this is comparatively much more
expensive and time consuming
meanwhile 3d cell culture systems can
offer increased complexity compared to
traditional 2d culture with increased
faithfulness to the nvivo environment
with minimal additional cost
the primary changes to cells in 3d are
shape motility and polarity as well as
tissue specific consequences
this table nicely summarizes a lot of
the key differences between 2d and 3d
culture
and includes less obvious but important
differences such as response to medium
and drugs
and stages of cell cycle vast changes in
biological behavior are seen in
different environments
some real world examples to demonstrate
these key differences are shown here
in the top panel 2d cell culture of
untransformed mammary epithelial cell
line mcf10a
and malignant breast cancer cell line
mdamb231
which look virtually indistinguishable
however the more
morphologic characteristics and
differences between these cell lines are
on full display when cultured in three
dimensions on major gel
the bottom panel shows an rna-seq
profile
and data from a same cell line grown in
2d and 3d
where thousands of genes were
differentially expressed between these
two conditions
both upregulated and downregulated shown
in red and blue
so from these two examples alone it's
clear that 3d culture alters cell
connectivity polarity
morphology gene expression as well as
not displayed here
metabolic radiance such as nutrients co2
and o2
proliferation as well as drug response
there are a variety of available 3d
culture methods including growth on a
substrate such as nature gel
growth embedded within a substrate and
suspension culture
which each produce their own advantages
and disadvantages and may work depending
upon your cell type and experimental
objectives
for example if you need to recover cells
at the end of an experiment
it's much easier to do so when grown
suspended in media rather than embedded
in a hydrogel
in deciding the best method of 3d
culture for you it's important to
consider factors necessary for your 3d
system
including or excluding extracellular
matrix components may dramatically
impact the growth of yourself
and may directly or indirectly change
results you're interested in obtaining
the ecm in vivo may include factors such
as matrix proteins
glycoproteins
hyaluronic acids proteoglycans
or growth factors all of which can
impact your research
it's also important to remember that
some ecm components when utilized as
coatings
can actually increase attachment of 2d
cell culture
so an example would be collagen coating
plates
where this will not achieve three cell
culture systems however when utilized
with fibers or pores
substrates such as collagen can serve as
a 3d environment so selecting the
correct ecm products
is very important in achieving 3d
culture systems
some terminology related to 3d cell
culture so
terms such as spheroids and organoids
are distinct and although sometimes used
interchangeably
do not describe the same thing spheroids
refer to 3d spherical cellular
aggregates
and not all cell lines that grow in 2d
will grow this way some examples are
spheroids are tumor spheres which are
formed from tumor cells
mammospheres which are from mammary
derived cells and hepatospheres which
are liver derived
organoids are 3d cell culture aggregates
generated from adult or embryonic stem
cells
these mimics are tissue of origin and
several examples are neurospheres which
are from neuronal stem cells and
embroidered bodies
as mentioned there are different ways to
achieve 3d culture
and these methods can be broadly
classified into scaffolding methods and
scaffold-free methods
hydrogels are the most commonly utilized
scaffold
structure for 3d culture these are water
swollen networks of polymers or
three-dimensional
cross-linked cross-linked network
scaffolds present tissue-like
flexibility and diffusion of nutrients
and co2o2 gradients
more similar to physiological conditions
than 2d culture
exam examples of hydrogels are mature
gel which is a gelatinous protein
mixture
polyethylene glycol conjugates
hyaluronic acid
alginate and max gel human ecm
which unlike nature gel which is an ecm
protein mixture derived from urine cells
is derived from human epithelial cells
the intention of hydrogel use is to
mimic structural integrity of the ecm
to aid in maintaining tissue
architecture and tissue specific
functions
as well as provide critical cell ecm
protein interaction
scaffolds usually require labor of
adding them to tissue culture dishes or
multi-well plates which can be tricky as
some are very difficult to work with
in achieving even spread within wells
and even layers between wells
the example shown here was a on the
right was a combination of alginate and
nature gel to embed
breast cancer cells in beads which you
can see in the picture in panel d
3d culture is a method whereby cells are
forced to float
attachment is prevented by continuous
movement of culture or agitation
or by the use of polymer coatings to
prevent attachment to a tissue culture
dish
some examples of plate types are low
attachment
ultra load attachment tissue culture
dishes which can be round or flat bottom
pictured here success in culturing using
these
culture methods really depends upon the
cell line or tissue type
and specific factors related to those
cell lines some
cell types easily assemble into
aggregates in these conditions and
secrete their own extracellular matrix
however some other cell types may be
more sensitive to the stress of this
type of culture
and may not survive or proliferate
there are also specialized 3d culture
methods which brad is going to discuss a
few examples here
thank you valerie so as bell just
mentioned
the the 3d uh cell culture technologies
that she just talked about
um where 3d models are created uh when
cells
are cultured in hydrogel um added to
wells
or in the ultra low attachment plates
that she just
mentioned where a single spheroid is
created per well
there are definitely other types of 3d
culture methods that are currently being
used
and while there are many i'm going to
focus on
the three that you see here on this
slide
so the first uh that we talk about and
you see the image
in the the top right corner of the slide
uh is called raft or which stands for
real architecture
for 3d tissue culture so raft
is a collagen based hydrogen hydrogel
scaffold
and here the cells are mixed with coals
liquid collagen
neutralization solution and media and
then added to the wells of a microplate
absorbers which you see kind of in the
second panel
in white are then added to the wells and
since the absorbers are porous they
basically wick away
the media leaving the cells and
the collagen fibers and they create
a consistent 120 micron thick
um uh hydrogel that the cells are
embedded into
then over time as the cells uh
propagates
they form either primary organoids or
tumeroids
depending on the cell model that's being
used
some advantages of this system are the
consistency of the gel layer across all
of the welds
and this obviously allows for robust
imaging to be performed
barrier models can also be created such
as
air liquid interface models as multiple
layers
of cells in the raft can also be created
the second technology that i'm going to
talk about and you see the images
towards the right and the bottom right
of the slide
is n3d technology and
the n3d takes advantage of magnetic
nanoparticles the nanoparticles are
added to the cells when they are still
in a tissue flask so still cultured in
2d
and then allow to attach to the cell the
cells are then removed
from the flask and added to wells of our
microplate that has been
placed on top of a magnetic plate where
the magnetic
or where the magnets are located in the
middle of the well
this serves to bring the cells together
to begin the aggregation process
and before i talk about the advantages i
just want to also mention that there has
been
an extensive amount of testing to ensure
that when the nanoparticles are
attached to the cell that this does not
hurt
any uh viability of the cells nor the
normal function
of the cells whether they're in 2d or 3d
so as i mentioned there are many
advantages to this technology
and that it can be used with cell types
as val just previously mentioned
that don't naturally form tight
spheroidal structures this also allows
for flat microplates to be used in an
assay
which can yield better image quality and
also makes it easier for media exchanges
to be performed in the wells when
using either manual pipetting or vacuum
aspiration
since the plate can again uh be placed
on top of a magnet once it uh when it
contains the 3d spheroid models
and then the exchanges can be can be
performed without removing the steroids
from the well
and then the final technology i'm going
to talk about and you can see the image
on the bottom left of the slide
is micro metal technology this is
similar
to other non-scaffold based round bottom
plate technologies
in that cells are still added to the
wells they fall to the bottom of a round
well and then are free to aggregate into
a spheroid
structure however as the image shows
here instead of forming just one
spheroid per well
each well is micro patterned to create
hundreds of small micro wells allowing
steroids to be formed in each of those
microwells the advantage here is the
ability to test
multiple concentrations of multiple test
molecules
in a single plate so instead of having
an n of one spheroid
in each well you can have an n of
greater than 200
making uh high throughput applications
easier to accomplish
so now that we've talked about all the
different types of
ways that cells can be cultured into 3d
structures
valerie is now going to continue by
talking about some different
considerations for performing
imaging
so of course one of the most obvious and
forefront
issues with imaging cells that are in 3d
is focus
with scaffold-free conditions we expect
free-floating cell aggregates to be in
multiple
focal planes and not only that but they
may also
move more readily so if you're moving a
dish around the
structures themselves may actually
almost slosh within the media
so tips for dealing with this include
delaying imaging after
your stage movement and this could be in
both manual and automated
imaging microscopes some instruments
such as the biotech imagers
also offer a slow carrier speed so when
you're bringing plates into the
instrument or ejecting them
this is used to help minimize disruption
of these
free-floating objects another tip that
can be incorporated into your protocol
is to centrifuge the plate to aid in
clustering cells together
if you're not using one of those
specialized methods that brought just
mentioned with the
magnetic technology as well as
another imaging tip would be to if
you're acquiring
images in a z stack so acquiring images
in multiple focal planes
if you take larger step sizes you can
cover broader depth
which could help capture more of your
objects of interest
another consideration is when you're
using
these plates that either have repellent
properties
or these polymer coatings across the
bottom intended to
prevent attachment of cells this may
alter autofocus metrics if you're using
an imager with autofocus
and autofocus can also be affected by
scaffolds such as auger or nitrogen so
these are things to consider
before you start imaging 3d culture
system
so additional imaging considerations
related to focal planing
includes these back so a little bit of
what we just talked about
and although it may seem natural to
acquire images to cover
all the focal planes of interest or all
the focal planes where your objects
reside
it may not be necessary so for example
although the spheres to the right in the
control and plus drug images
were embedded in nature gel and resided
in multiple focal planes
the effect of drug addition which was
cell death which is visualized here by
cleve caspase-3 staining which is the
green that you see
is readily apparent from an image in a
single plane so although these are 3d
objects it may not be necessary
to image in multiple planes to answer
your research question
it may help to collect images in a
single plane first as a place to start
and determine if critical information is
missed or if your experimental question
could be addressed just from taking a
single imaging plane alone
if you need to take multiple staffed
images the thickness and the number of
slices
should be considered as the more images
you acquire
this equates to more time
and finally a few tips for working with
various substrates
it's important to level your plate when
adding nature gel manually
so the focal height is consistent
between wells which will aid you
later on in imaging this uniformity may
also be helped by adding
90 90 of your total volume allowing that
to gel
and then adding your final 10 which
leads to more
consistency and uniformity
so now we have a variety of different
experimental examples
the first of which is kinetic sphere
proliferation which brad's going to
discuss
okay thank you again valerie so in
uh the example that you're seeing here
the goal was to demonstrate the ability
of
biotech's lifestyle imaging systems
which includes
our citation imagers as well as the
lionheart fx
as well as the gen5 cellular analysis
software
to perform 3d spirit proliferations
which is a very common
type of athlete procedure performed with
different 3d structures so here
pink one uh pancreatic carcinoma cells
were
added to wells of a 96 well u-bottom
ultra low attachment uh spheroid
microplate at concentrations of either
500 cells per well as you can see in the
first four columns of
the of the plate and the image shown on
the left of the slide
or with a thousand cells per well shown
uh which were added to columns five
through eight um
of the plates after addition of the
cells
they were then allowed to aggregate into
uh spheroid models following aggregation
media was
automatically removed from the wells
using the
automated media exchange module on
biotech's multiflo fx which i'm going to
talk
to more about in a later slide and then
replaced with media containing varying
uh concentrations of camtasia to inhibit
proliferation
the plate was then placed into the
biospa
and automatically transferred to the
citation size to capture images of the
spheroids once per day
and we use the z-stacking capability and
the
gen 5 software to capture images at
multiple z-planes using
similar to what what valerie just talked
about to
ensure that we captured in focus images
of all portions of the steroids
gen 5 then created a z projected image
from all the slices yielding a final in
focus
image to be used for analysis and
criteria were set in the cellular
analysis steps to place accurate
object masks around the projected
spheroid images
despite the differing sizes since the
spheroids had a high degree
of circularity we were also able to
calculate volume measurements
which were then plotted for the
different concentrations of camp to
season
tested over time which you can see in
the two graphs on the right side of the
slide
and then that allowed for the effect of
the drug
on proliferation to be easily and
accurately determined
in the next example we demonstrate the
ability to
use the instrumentation and software for
3d tumor invasion assays another
very commonly performed assay procedure
so here again we use 96 well round
bottom cell repellent microplates
for turmeric formation in this case
however following the aggregation and
media removal
cold matrigel mixed with varying
concentrations of the inhibitor molecule
was added back to the wells and allowed
to gel around the spheroids
after the matrigel head had
head gels media was added on top
also containing the inhibitor the plates
were again placed into the biospa
and transferred to the citation for
imaging every 12 hours
and every 24 hours the plates
were transferred to the multiflo fx for
media exchanges to ensure that fresh
media was
in contact with the steroid models
through the entire incubation period
and as you can see in the image at the
top left it's critical to be able to
accurately image the highly intricate
invadapodia of the invading 3d structure
therefore we captured multiple images
again in a z-stack so that the
invadopodia at different z-planes
would be imaged in focus in addition
since invasion was also taking place in
the x and y axis
we also included a two column by two row
montage
to ensure the entire invading structure
was captured
within the images gen 5 allowed
the raw images to first be stitched
together for each z
plane and then following that uh by
performing a z projection
to create a final detailed image for
analysis
in this case we used a co-cultured cell
model that include gfb expressing
u87 or ln-229 glioblastoma cells
and rfe expressing primary fibroblasts
so that by capturing images
in the bright fields gfp or rfp channels
we were able to monitor
levels of invasion not only from the
entire structure but also from
individual cell types included in the
model
and finally again using gel gen 5
cellular analysis
in the images captured in the bright
field channel we were able to put
accurate detailed object masks around
the entire 3d structure then
to separate out the area covered solely
by the invader podia we
applied a secondary mask interior of the
primary mask
as you see with the image at the top
right of the slide this
allows for quantification of the area in
between the two
masks and when plotted over time enables
one to see the difference in the
invasive characteristics
of the two different glioblastoma cell
types
in the third example we're looking at
quantifying the effect of compound
treatment
on primary small intestinal organoids
formed from stem cells
here again the cells are embedded in
matrigel and allow
to proliferate and differentiate into
the intestinal organoid model
a characteristic of intestinal organoids
is that under
normal conditions cells around the
exterior maintain their stemness
and create buds coming off the round
portion of the structure
as you can see in the bottom left image
on the slide
treatment affecting the health of the
organoids causes a loss of stemness
and a decrease in budding by placing
object masks around the organoids
using gen5 cellular analysis and the
bright field channel
we can then use two calculated metrics
those being the calculated
area and perimeter to create a custom
metric
known as spikiness where area is in the
numerator
and perimeter is in the denominator of
the fraction used for the calculation
therefore the more bugs on an organoid
the larger the perimeter is in relation
to the area
and the higher the spikiness value
another way we can quantify budding
is by using the spot counting capability
in gen 5.
in the example shown here gapy and an
edu
proliferation stain are added to the
organoids
dappy stains the entire organoid while
the edu
stains highly proliferate proliferative
areas of the organoid or in this case
those containing stem cells in the buds
primary masks are placed around the
entire organoid using the dappy signal
and then using the spot counting module
additional masks are placed around the
buds
using the signal from the edu stain the
number of spots or in
our case buds is calculated and can be
plotted
against the concentration of the added
treatment
to ascertain the effect on small
intestinal organoid health
and then in the fourth example here we
are examining the effect of diclofenac
to induce mitochondrial oxidative stress
on 3d spheroidal liver micro tissues
for long-term liver toxicity testing
following a 72
hour treatment with varying
concentrations of the drug
we added a hoax 33342 nuclear probe
and mitosox mitochondrial superoxide
indicator
the signal from the hoax probe captured
in the dappy channel was used to place
object masks around each spheroid then
the mean
rfu signal from the mito mitosox probe
captured with the texas red channel was
quantified
within the object mask
the mean signals in addition to the norm
uh normalized
ratio of the mean signal from the
concentrations of diclofenac tested
compared to the mean from the negative
control
can then be plotted in terms of the
dichlophonic concentrations to determine
the effect of the drug to induce
oxidative stress
on the test 3d cell model
and valerie is now going to continue
with
additional examples so valerie
thanks brad so our final example would
be a
um example of high content screening in
a 3d system
so cells could be seated and allowed to
form spheroids and once those spheroids
are generated a compound library could
be added across wells
of a multi-well plate after incubation
with
with this compound library a molecular
probe could be added to visualize cell
death
so shown in the image here yoyo one
iodide was added to indicate cell death
imaging could be executed at each well
in one or two planes and this
fluorescent indicator of cell death
could then be quantified using software
such as gen 5
the expression of this fluorescent
indicator of cell death could be
normalized to bright field images or
a nuclear marker such as dappy
thereby determining which compounds are
effective at
inducing cell death
so as mentioned previously brad talked
about media exchange using the amx
system of biotech and here he's going to
explain
in a little bit more detail about how
that system worked
thanks again val so uh as
anyone knows who has worked with
unattached spheroid models it is
difficult at best to perform meat
exchanges or washes in this type of
setting
where the spheroids are not anchored to
the plates or hydrogel
the use of typical vacuum-based
aspiration is definitely out of the
question
and even when performing these steps
manually with a multi-channel pipette
is a highly stressful process with a
high risk of still removing
spheroids from the wells so to simplify
this procedure and make the process much
more repeatable
biotech has created the amx
or again automated media exchange module
to be used with the multiflo fx
the instrument has been re-engineered so
that the secondary peristaltic pump
basically runs backwards allowing for
aspiration from microplate wells
the primary parry pump still runs in a
forward motion
to allow dispensing the cassettes are
also modified so that
instead of using non-contact dispense
heads
each set of tubing is attached to
stainless steel tubes that make contact
with the liquid
in the wells two additional
modifications to the instrument
also help to ensure that steroids are
not removed
the first is that the arms holding the
attached
aspirate and dispense heads can be
controlled in the x and y axes
to move the tubes to the corner of the
wells away from the spheroids
a change in the base code of the
multiflora effects also allows for slow
movement
of the barrels of the peristaltic pumps
which serves
to prevent dislodging of the spheroids
from the middle of the well
the combination of these enhancements
creates an
automated process that can accurately
and repeatedly
perform single media exchanges or
multi-step washes
in 96 or 384 steroid microplates
allowing
long-term assays to then be performed
with
unattached spheroid models in a robust
manner
so uh valerie is now going to
continue with talking about other
imaging and automation
solutions that biotech can offer thanks
ben
so as brad mentioned in several of his
example experiments as he was moving
through
a lot of the biotech instruments were
utilized for the execution of those
experiments
and some of which that he mentioned were
the lionheart and the citation so shown
on this side at the top left
we have both the lionheart lx and fx
which are automated microscopes offered
by biotech
and on the right uh you see an example
of a citation
uh biotech offers citations seven five
and one these are cell imagers as well
as
they have the capability to be plate
readers as well so multi-mode readers
all contained within one instrument and
in the bottom lower panel you see
position between the citation
and the liquid handling module is the
biosphere
which is an automated incubator that
could pair with both the citation and
the liquid handling
for a complete walk-away solution
so some conclusions from today's webinar
are that there are
distinct morphologic and physiologic
differences between 2d and 3d culture
and 3d culture really allows for the
study of cellular responses in a setting
that's
more resembling in vivo environment
there's been tremendous effort over the
last
several decades even to put into the
development of a variety of different 3d
culture systems and they're
continuing to improve as well as the
adoption of 3d culture systems
um which are applicable to many
different fields such as drug discovery
cell
cancer cell biology stem cell study
engineering functional tissues for
implantation virology aging metabolism
and many more
there are also many imaging
considerations when you're
starting to determine what objectives
you have from your 3d
systems and experiments some of which
include quantification
of metrics that brad discussed a lot in
his example such as fluorescence
diameter or area so what's required to
really address your
research questions as well as what
images
are really necessary to obtain this
information so is these stacking
required do you need to take images in
multiple planes
if you're taking images in different
planes as there are different projection
methods that could be best
um and also defining different
focal heights or imaging across plates
is something that
it certainly needs to be worked out and
may require some troubleshooting
to really obtain the best results for
your experiment thank you valerie brad
for your terrific presentation
we'll now look at some of the questions
that came in if you haven't done so
please submit any additional questions
with the chat feature and we'll get to
as many of these as we have time for
okay so we're going to get get started
with
the questions that we've seen um come in
during the um during the playback of the
recording there's a number of
uh really great questions and like uh
like was
previously mentioned we will certainly
do our best to
get through all of them or as many as we
can
one of the first questions that came in
was asking about
problems or things that the
industry is facing as far as working
with
uh different um 3d cell culture methods
so
while obviously we could we could speak
for probably at least an hour or more
on just this question alone um uh
some things that come to mind uh in you
know talking to colleagues and
and um so on and so forth would be
you know as we as we spoke about in the
recording
uh first would be what type of um what
type of plates
uh do you want to be um
using and what type of culture method as
far as you know does
your does your cell model
require uh or do best uh
being um and embedded into
you know some sort of hydrogel uh you
know and
um and then in that case what type of uh
plate whether you know would it be best
in a you know in a platform type of a
plate um
obviously certain cell models require
um you know certain ecms uh
to be um to be present and to really
create the best um
and most in vivo type uh type model
um so so that that
kind of leads me into you know my second
part of the answer is
uh looking at not just including
if you're working with a cancer model
not just necessarily including
the uh the cancer cell line but uh but
think about
the whole um you know security model
uh that would exist in vivo so you know
think about
what type of stromal cells uh you know
would you want to include a fibroblast
maybe a cancer you know calf a
cancer-associated fibroblast
uh macrophage you know so on and so
forth
so really trying to recreate
um as best as possible the uh the 3d
indivo
environment and not just having a single
cell type
to include another thing to consider
would be that uh the media
um again not uh you know just as with
with cell types and with uh plate models
uh not all medias are the things so it's
not necessarily a one size fits all
so think about what what components in
the media
would be would again best
mimic the 3d environment in vivo
that you are then trying to communicate
in vitro
environment so again those are those are
just a few things that come
that come to mind um if you have further
questions we can certainly
um you know have a more of a dialogue
offline uh the next question was
regarding to
the specific to the wrath technique and
whether this yields uh steroidal models
that are relatively consistent in size
so my answer would be yes
when i've worked with this model i've
definitely seen greater um
consistency in the size of the the tumor
into steroids uh organoids uh obviously
it's not going to be exactly the same
but um but i do see a greater
consistency in both size
area and
volume um so then i'm gonna
hand it over to valerie and she's gonna
take the next couple questions
hi everyone thank you again for joining
us we have some really great questions
coming in
i'm gonna try to lump a couple that are
similar together and try to answer a few
at the same time
so we asked how do you do the staining
of cat space 3 in nature gel
and we also received questions about
what strategies are recommended
about antibody staining or
immunofluorescence of steroids
in nature gel and other 3d models so
i'll try to cover all of that
in one answer so the staining of
caspase-3 that was shown here was
actually an antibody
specific to cleaved caspase-3 and when
cells are embedded in matrigel you can
fix them
directly residing in the major gel
for example if you have nature gel in an
eight chain birth slide
with cells embedded in or grown
at least on residing on top of them they
will have some retention to the nature
gel even if they're sitting on top and
grown
in maybe a dilute major gel media
so important things to think about are
your fixative concentrations
um to gently wash them so you add
antibody the same way you would
if you're doing immunofluorescence in 2d
so you dilute it
you would still block ahead of adding
your antibody you would do gentle washes
if you're doing this manually maybe
pipetting from a corner directly
trying to stay away from the spheroids
that you have
so that you're not losing them in the
washing processes
also it's important to remember if
you're working with nature gel
nature gel or the human
almost equivalent of nature gel ecm
components
think about the source of this so major
gel itself is derived from now sarcoma
cells
so if you're using mass antibodies
you're going to get more background
um also if you're not working with
nature jealous if your cells are free
floating
in something like the ultra low
attachment plates so they're floating
around in media
it's possible if you wanted to stain
them as live cells which was done in the
one
slide where you talked about an
experiment where you could do
a high content screening in a form with
3d culture
thinking about the concentrations that
you're adding and really troubleshooting
if you're adding directly to media
with free floating cells kind of
balancing the background that you're
getting from
a dye or an antibody that's not being
taken up into the cell
with adding enough that you're getting
through staining
is something that you kind of need to
work out and troubleshoot it's also
possible to
to collect spheroids that are grown in
ultra low attachment conditions so if
they're free floating
you can gently collect the spheres while
they're still in media
to either a conical tube or an epidural
tube
you can gently centrifuge them and there
are protocols for this
you would then add fixative directly to
the cells
the spheroids that you've collected and
you can stain and wash and go through
the normal process of immunofluorescence
veining
to the spheroids themselves one thing to
remember though is
the size of your spheroid may limit the
ability of
some of these antibodies to penetrate
all the way into the center of the
sphere so if you're using
imaging where you really care about full
pen entrance it's important to think
about the size of your sphere
and how you can really get those
antibodies in
um this is also going to depend upon the
cell type too so if they're really tight
dense spheroid aggregates it may be
harder to penetrate those as well so if
you see only peripheral staining
this could be a technical effect rather
than biological result
so those are just a few um
considerations and and ways that you
could achieve immunofluorescence
staining
or staining with dyes there was a
question about what
one of the dies was on a slide and i
think it came up during that high
throughput stain
slide which was marking cell death and
that was
something called yo-yo one iodide and
that's essentially a derivative of
proportium iodide they come in multiple
different fluorescent channels
so if you're trying to pair them with an
antibody that you
have conjugated or you can kind of
tailor it to your needs
i'll hand it back to brad if you want to
field another question
sure sure um okay so uh there's another
one about
um consistency of uh steroid size
um in some of the different uh
3d cell culture system that i had talked
about um again we we covered the raft
um that you know you definitely get good
consistency but
you know they're still obviously the
depending on where this
um the cells are within the
hydrogel and how the proliferate can
lead to a little bit of
variability the the other two that i
talked about um
the n3d and the microwell are very
uh are very consistent in 3d obviously
you would
put in you know a set number of cells
into each well and then um you know
again using the the magnetics they bring
themselves together so you would get
very consistent steroids
uh from well the well the same as seen
with the
the microwell systems that typically a
very consistent
number of cells fall into each of the
microwell
um when aggregation takes place and you
get a very consistent
number of um
number of cells per um per spheroid um
there was another question about uh tips
for working with pancreatic
cancer organoids so
from what i've seen interacting with
a number of customers working with these
types of organoids it's definitely best
and you get the best
results when embedding them in some sort
of
a hydrogel uh many people have seen
are working with major gel but others i
have seen uh prefer the collagen just
because of the increased uh consistency
um over over the major zone
from lots a lot um you definitely do not
need a thick hydrogel
uh to work with these types of um uh
organoids
so then my ears can can work quite well
um
and and then as far as the imaging
itself
uh from what i've seen if you just are
doing um you know some of the counting
uh looking at um generating the the area
and perimeter data that i you know that
that we showed and we talked about
um earlier um then a lower objective
works very nicely uh for that but if you
want to you know really look at
subcellular structures
um uh you know you can certainly use
you know like a 20x or potentially a 40x
objective
uh like again for what i've uh when i've
worked with
the um the small intestinal organoids
you know to see the
the crypts uh within the um
the buds of the um of the organoids that
can easily be
handled with again something like a um
you know a slightly higher power
um objective and then um kind of going
on
with with that there was a question
about
whether the um the organoins that were
imaged
were they fixed uh or lies so in the
example that uh that we showed here
those were those were fixed samples
however
in other situations uh i've certainly um
imaged uh live organoids in in wells
just
using simple brightfield uh and then
again we can you know we can
um use the change in the bright field
signal to
um you know you know to be able to mask
the
overnoids and get a lot of different um
uh
information um from there and then i was
also gonna
answer there's a question about is uh
image prime uh which is one of our
versions
of the gen five software uh necessary
for um for the tumor invasion analysis
so
uh the answer to that one is kind of a
yes and no
uh you can do it either way um in the
example that i was showing
um with the uh the place that i was
using
we were basically generating one
tumoroid one invading tumoroid per well
so
in that case you could use the image
plus
and you could do you could basically
generate
or perform two separate cellular
analysis so you would set
in the first one you would set uh the
criteria to put an object mask around
the
entire uh structure and
then you would perform a second cellular
analysis to get that tighter
interior mask and then gen 5 can still
do the calculations
to subtract the differences between the
two areas
covered so again that can be
accomplished with the gen 5 image plus
now if you were using a method that you
had multiple organoids
per well then the image prime which
allows you to do the primary and
secondary masking
specific to each organoid that you might
have imaged
um then that would uh then that would
come in
handy there so again it depends on the
plate and the model
that you're that you're using okay
um i'm gonna kick it back to
uh valerie and i think we'll better
answer a couple more questions
thanks brad so we have a couple that are
somewhat related so i'm going to try and
knock out a few of them
in one shot here too so we have the
question of which of your systems can
take
images and do analysis for kinetic
sphere proliferation
we also have a question about the main
differences between the lion heart and
the citation imaging system
so both the lion heart and the citation
can execute kinetic experiments
the differences between the lion heart
and the citation are the
citation also has the ability to
contain a plate reader so this has a
multi-mode slate reader
portion available so space available in
the instrument itself which is why it's
that larger
box compared to the stage that you can
see in the lionheart
so um the lionheart also has the ability
to be paired with
a humidity chamber so for long-term
kinetic experiments where you really
want to leave the plate inside the
instrument
lionheart has not only for both the line
heart and the citation have
temperature control and the capability
to have
gas control so co2 and nitrogen
regulation of oxygen as well
however the lionheart does have humidity
control as well
so if you really need a long-term
kinetic experiment where you need to
leave your plate in for
several days at the time and you want to
image
very frequently or infrequently the
lionheart would be your best option for
that
the citation has the ability to do
kinetic as well
and this instrument can also be paired
with our biospa
which is um i think was shown on the
side of our
with our instruments as well so that's
our our self-contained incubating system
this can be set with a schedule using
our software
to deliver plates from the incubating
system directly to the citation
and then back to the instrument so if
you have um
multiple plates on different schedules
you can program all that into
the bias bar and you can have the bios
bottle move the plates directly to your
citation
so it's a walk away solution you don't
have to be there for that um and then
the citation can perform your imaging
we also have the ability on both of
these experiments or sorry um
both of these instruments rather to do
this kinetic
um discontinuous kinetic experiments so
you can actually set an experiment where
say you wanted to read the plate once
every day
um but you don't want to take up the
instrument other people in your lab need
to use it
so you can set up an experiment where
[Music]
you say i'm going to read the plates
once every day you
pop the plate into the instrument you do
your imaging
run and then you return the plate to
your phone incubator
and then the next day you come back and
you'd
get ready to do your imaging again you'd
load your same plate and you actually
open that
experiment and it appends the data so
it'll still
function in the same manner as a kinetic
experiment where it's comparing your
data points over time and collecting
them and
linking them all together but it gives
you the ability to
have spaced out time points without
occupying a machine
i think this is also kind of addressing
the question we have a question that
says
imaging question for imaging analysis of
384 spheroids how do you
make this a high-throughput endeavor so
that could be something i'm assuming
you're using a 300 uh 384 well plate
with hopefully one steroid per well
if you're imaging over multiple time
points it depends upon
what you're trying to achieve if you
really need close time points together
you could set up a connecticut run or
kinetic experiment dictating which
the length of time between imaging runs
and how many
imaging rooms you want to capture the
software will
link all of those points together for
you
and if you wanted to space them out
again you could use this discontinuous
kinetic feature
i think there was also a question about
the name of the software that we had
mentioned
so all of our which is called gen 5.
okay i think i'll take a few more i
think we've got a time for a few more
questions
there was a question about is it
possible to image
uh 3d neuronal um
uh structures and the answer to that is
yes um i've personally done some
applications where we started out
with uh progenitor cells and then
differentiated them
into either
neurons or astrocytes or
oligodendrocytes
and um uh imaging that
you know and performing the
differentiation that can be done either
uh in 2d or actually in a 3d type of a
configuration and then
we've definitely done uh imaging of um
of the the differentiated um neurons
uh over time uh you can also and you
know obviously that can be done
just with um label free and something
like a bright field or phase contrast
you can also
add uh you know into antibody um
staining my valley was talking about to
you know to confirm uh differentiation
of the cells into the into the different
uh lineages and then obviously you would
just add
uh full reference imaging to um uh to
accomplish that as well so that
certainly
is possible um there's another one
about uh going back to the organoids and
talking about whether in the gen 5
software we can
calculate a circularity measurement so
the answer to that is also
uh yes so any time that
we use the software in a cellular
analysis
um step
to place object masks automatically
around
um objects whether that you know a 2d
cell
or some sort of a 3d structure you have
like a number of different metrics
that uh can be calculated and have the
ability to be captivated with the
software
uh we were talking you know i was
talking about uh
area and perimeter but you can also
quantify things like circularity
that's easily done so that would be
similar
in a way to that spikiness
calculation that i was that i was
talking about basically runs from you
know it's from zero to one
uh you know so that can also be used
um to examine um you know the the
level of budding um in the
in the intestinal intestinal organoids
um and uh then there was another one
about uh optimal inner intervals for
for z stacking um valerie did a nice job
of
talking about that earlier but again you
know just to kind of reiterate what she
said that
um you know it it depends on you know
the level of detail that you need from
your um uh out of the experiment that
you're performing if you're basically
looking at kind of you know something
like
proliferation and you just want to see
changes in areas then
uh maybe taking less
[Music]
you know a lower amount of slices and a
larger gap between
uh we do a great job because obviously
it's going to make the
the imaging faster and still going to
give you the same
type of data but again it depends on you
know really what you
what you need to um the information that
you need to get out
um and then um the lesson that i was
going to cover quickly and then
we'll see if um valerie wants to answer
a last couple
uh it was asking about the ability of
our
biospa and citation to perform tumor
invasion assays and again that certainly
can be
accomplished that can be done with the
biospa
and really any of our citation images
simply because you with with any of the
citations you have the ability to
perform
um you know both bright fields and
fluorescence imaging
and you know you can you can transfer
uh the plates to and from the biospawn
up to the citation
and and do any of those types of uh
types of applications so valerie did you
have any
uh last questions that you wanted to
answer then i think we're
we're almost to the top of the hour
sure so there's a couple about
sectioning the organ
there's one thing how do you section the
organoids
what do you recommend to transfer them
and there's another question asking if
they need to be
sectioned in order to image them so if
they're retained within a hydrogel
something like a neutrogen and you have
a system
such as ours either the lionheart or the
citation
where you can leave your cells embedded
in
in that substrate you can actually image
keeping them in the vessel that they're
grown in using our system so
both of our systems have an inverted
fluorescent microscope
so if you're imaging you can image
directly in your vessel
both of our systems can take vessels
that fit the footprint of the 96-volt
plate so
multi-well plates we have an adapter for
our systems for eight chambered slides
so um they can actually be retained
within
the hydrogel itself fixed where where
they were grown
stained right there in an image right
there if you do want to take them out
and you wanted to um one of the
questions i think was with regards to
sectioning them similarly to what you
would do with um
like a histologic sample i've actually
taken cells out of ultra low attachment
plates so if they're floating in media
collected them very gently fix them
and then embedded them myself in agar
so you can make a percentage of auger
the same way you would for
a dna gel and you can embed those
spheroids directly in the auger
within an epi tube and then process it
the same way you would
a histologic fixed tissue sample
so you can perform
slices after it's processed the same way
you would like an ffpe sample
all right well thank you so much
unfortunately that's all the time that
we have for today
i want to thank our presenters val and
brad and once again
thank you to everyone who joined us
today and submitted all your great
questions
if we didn't get to your question during
the q a portion we'll
be sure to follow up with you uh in an
email and if you would like more
information about biotech's products and
services
please visit our website at
www.biotech.com
we hope you enjoyed today's presentation
and have a great rest of your day